surging along the east coast of Africa
two of the world's swiftest strongest
currents the Mozambique and Agulhas
connect warm equatorial waters to cooler
water masses to the south their
upwelling currents bring deep cold water
to the surface and create some of the
richest biological areas of the sample
from South Africa to Somalia more than
11,000 species of marine plants and
animals thrive along the western edge of
the Indian Ocean sandy beaches provide
nesting sites for about 70% of the
world's marine turtles leatherbacks
loggerheads
hawksbills and greens
coral reef springs the shore and the
legendary offshore islands in a dazzling
architecture of shape and color
the Carl here comes in many sizes and
textures from smooth Bolger Carl's
lettuce Carl's
great green curls the elegant lines of
Stankiewicz various kinds of moray eels
are at home in these structures these
graceful creatures have a second set of
jewels in their throats to capture and
hold their prey
the upwelling of currents could also
bring the light exotic creatures from
the deep the western Indian Ocean is
home to a legendary creature the
coelacanth once thought to have died out
with the dinosaurs the capture of one of
these fishes in 1938 sparked a debate
among scientists about how the
coelacanth fit into the evolution of
animals its pair of lobe fins make it
unlike other fish an ocean that harbors
such a living fossil probably has some
other surprises yet the biggest surprise
is that so little of the western Indian
Ocean has been explored in part
exploration has length behind the basic
survival coastal communities so fish the
orders for centuries using methods that
have been passed down through the
generations seaweed farming has also
provided sustenance for communities near
the shore and has allowed them to export
this key ingredient to be used for foods
medicines and cosmetics
but these practices have been
overshadowed by large-scale commercial
fishing operations which have steadily
depleted these waters of rich
populations of fish people are awakening
to the needs of the western Indian Ocean
are beginning to protect critical areas
within this magical place